and for the rangers tonight on the mound
it'll be jordan lyles a right-hander
coming off a tough start he had a rough
one
in his last start against the cleveland
indians this will be the eighth pitch of
the at-bat tapia is going again a swing
and a miss strike three throw down to
second a good one
got him at second base
welcome back jonah heim that was a
strike to the bag
well austin gomber on the hill getting
the start today his 23rd of the season
out on the road this is his 14th start
here's the 2-2
and gomber gets him so rocky's leave a
runner stranded nathaniel lowe
left-handed hitting first baseman he's
banning 257
as nathaniel lowe goes after the first
pitch
hits his ball well deep out to left that
one is gone
low goes the other way
it's his 14th home run of the year and
he has the rangers in front one nothing
pitch fastball at 88 miles an hour
and he crushes it 103 off the bat they
were trying to go away it's that middle
it's a good example of him we've talked
a lot about his ability to pull the ball
in the air it's on a strength gets the
ball on the ground to that side but you
see how he takes a pitch down the middle
first pitch of the f-bat
sam hilliard now
sam with the average at 197.
there's the 1-1 out to left field and
that's deep has a chance at the warning
track
how about it sam hilliard
hometown homers for the texas boys
so awesome ninth home run 20 rbis and
that's the thing with sam when he makes
contact they usually go a long way don't
mess with hillard
slamming sam
let's try struck out
in the first inning and he hits this
ball out to left field that one carrying
well peters is back he leaps and makes
the catch
that's just great athleticism the
reaction while moving like that going
backward that is tremendous back to back
two out walks rangers trying to build
something in this third
oh he's wobbling a little bit here
and low goes after the first pitch
shoots that one through the left field
base hit here comes garcia he'll score
heading to third peters he's in safely
and the throw gets away and allows low
to go to second base
rbi single for nathaniel
and the rangers have a two-to-one lead
base is full spot now for jonah hein
[Applause]
and it's on the ground
third base mcmahon goes to second
interesting choice they force out solac
to in the inning eight nine and one do
up for texas tavares doro
hernandez
tavares
gets into this one deep out to right
it's gone
back back-to-back knights
and leone tavares leaves the yard again
it's three to one rangers
they tried to go away again they know
that is a weakness and it is when that
location is missed we use that phrase
you can't miss your pitch that is his
pitch a fastball down the middle they
wanted to go away off the plate around
the corner
and he made them pay
make it to the fifth any bottom third of
the order for the rockies
2-2 pitch
and strike three
diaz couldn't quite stop himself
another strikeout this one to start the
fifth inning
and that strike three called he gets
hampson looking that's a fifth strikeout
tonight
the wind up in the 3-2
slider strike three called
lyle strikes out the side in order in
the fifth
and the rangers have him on the corners
on the ground third base the throat of
first a little bit high
but it's in time and garcia goes diving
into the plate meanwhile with the
rangers fourth run of the night so
solace picks up the rbi
it's a 5-3 put out
but it's 4-1 4-1 texas leading here as
we go to the top half of the seventh
inning and i'm out there
krone high in the air to right field
that ball has some carry to it keeping
at the wall can't get it
how about cj krone stay hot it is still
the month of august after all
and the rockies close the gap to four to
two and here's ryan mcmahon
and the one-two pitch coming to mcmahon
breaking ball this is hit well to right
field going back garcia that one's over
and out of here
back to back
crone and mcmahon and it's a one-run
game rockies trail 4-3
[Applause]
this time it was a curveball mack has
two hits on this road trip
two home runs one in chicago one here in
texas
[Applause]
he walks two on one out this inning
he's been a good one
a real good one for them whoa did he go
he did
and he strikes out for the second out of
the inning
and krone puts it on the ground ranging
to his left solace first in time
a close play at first but solac gets it
done
and the inning is over
so barred the hard-throwing right-hander
to nick solank he's driven in a run he's
walked twice
and he flares one out to right field it
is a nine-game hitting streak for nick
solac
runner going
and bart will get him to strike out diaz
the throw down
and he got him
that was great on so many different
levels
but first the runner takes off
that he knows right he almost stopped
running like he thought it was going to
be ball a ball and he wouldn't have to
go but watch the hitter fall and then
fortunately he ducked and then trevor
just a sweet little tag right onto the
chest
spencer patton taking over now for the
rangers trying to lock this one down
would be his 30th game of the season
this one
out to center field that's going to hang
up for tavares went away
[Applause]
this one in the air now the right side
long run for garcia and he makes the
catch two away
the one-two pitch and a swing out of his
strike three patton locks it down to the
ninth
boy that was a
nice and tidy
ninth in for spencer patton
you